[Music]
hi everyone i am alam javed
i am an undergrad final year student
at amit university noida india
i am a research fellow at mind biotech
and the
project i'm currently working on is
identification of biomarkers leading to
alzheimer's based on rna sequence of
artistic and control cortex
so alzheimer's disease is
a disease which affects mostly the brain
and causes a symptom called dementia
it is said to be progressive cerebrum
disorder which is irreversible and that
gradually destroys thinking ability and
old memories
it is said to be a disorder which is
irreversible and that gradually destroys
thinking ability and old memories
in this picture you can see how a
healthy brain
gets affected by alzheimer's disease
alzheimer's disease and autistic
spectrum disorder
autism spectrum disorder and alzheimer's
disease are neurodevelopmental and
neurodegenerative disorders respectively
with devastating effects
it is of utmost curiosity that these
disorders
express at different stages of life and
there is an involvement of certain
susceptible genes
this genetic basis makes the background
of common associations like memory
deficiency cognition changes
demyelination oxidative stress and
inflammation
an integral part of food disorders
the methodology
which i used was a pipeline was run
using the data set
which was rna sequence of autistic
control cortex a comparison was made
between the autistic and control cortex
genes
comparative analysis done to analyze the
sample between the groups by
running the expression pipeline on t
bioinfo server
as a result desect 2 was used to obtain
differential express genes enrichment
analysis is used to obtain gang pathways
gse
functional enrichment analysis was used
to obtain geo-enriched pathways
and the network
comparative analysis comparative
analysis consists of pipelines to obtain
differentially expressed genes keck
pathways geo-enriched genes among the
groups
desect 2 is a tool used for differential
gene expression analysis of rna sequence
data
enrichment analysis identifies
biological pathways that is keg pathways
gsea analysis is done to determine set
of genes which show statistically
significant concordant differences
between two biological states that is go
pathway
like here we can see how the pipeline
was run
first we click on the start button v
and then desect 2
is selected then enrichment analysis and
gsa
according to the requirement and then we
end the pipeline the parameters are
fed into the pipeline
volcano plot buff it is performed under
the two conditions the adjusted p
p-value at y-axis
and
log to full change at x-axis
uh it determines significant
differentially expressed genes genes
which are having negative log to full
change value will be considered
will be considered as downregulated
genes whereas the positive log to full
change value to be considered as
upregulated genes
it basically determines significant
differentially expressed genes
the blue
the blue area represents
significant genes and red area
represents significant
differentially expressed genes
genes which are having
negative log-to-fold change value will
be considered as downregulated value
whereas
positive log to full change value as
upregulated value basically the higher
gene in the plot is more significance
keg enriched pathways
keck provides information of enrichment
of genes in the area displayed on the
basis of two parameters count and p
adjusted
value which shows distribution of genes
as you can see here that count shows the
number of genes involved in the pathway
and color represents the
adjusted value
keng enrich pathways provides
information about various pathways that
are either are activated or suppressed
due to the upregulation or down
regulation of the gene respectively
pathways corresponding to the highest
quantity of upregulated genes are highly
activated and pathways corresponding to
higher count
sorry number down regulated genes are
highly suppressed so basically the
highest count of upregulated genes is
associated with
cytokine cytokine interactions as you
can see here
it has the highest count number
and the down related gene is associated
with tca or citrate cycle as we can see
it over here
network blocked it is basically a graph
that analyzes the pathways in the
network based on the full change value
size of dot in the code depicts the
number of genes involved in particular
pathway the color indicates the full
change value
it analyzes the genes that are included
in the particular pathway the dot size
depicts the number of genes involved
color of the
dot
full change value shows the full change
value and decrease in the fold change
leads to increase in gene expressed in
pathway as we can see that there are a
few core hub genes which over here
are
is
n
l r
and over here it is sox4 cnmd
and tspo
so the key findings which
i have noted from keg analysis is
possible association can be made between
suppressed pathway of citrix cycle or
tsa and cytokine cytogram receptor
interaction
from volcano plot the an upregulated
genes
is lil rb1 and
socs3
also we found hub genes which can be
used as biomarker network plot which are
n
l rp9 elf 4 tspo cnmd
future directions researchers can
perform experiments focusing on these
particular
gene found in the study and correlate
their upregulated down and down
regulated genes with disease progression
thank you so much
[Music]
you